Welcome, everyone. What a delight it is,
as we're closing the meeting, to see a full room.
Thank you everyone for coming. I want to start by saying what a privilege
it's been to co-chair this meeting with my colleague, Dr.
Alice Shaw, and to have the privilege of having worked with our
immediate past president, Dr. Lillian Tsou, and with
AACR team, including Dr. Lisa Hauben and Dr.
Eleanor Rollo, and with our CEO, Dr. Marge Foti.
The AACR team is extraordinary, and the work that goes into putting this
meeting together is incredible.
One thing I hope you all feel right now, and I feel it,
is inspired.
There's never been a more important time for cancer research, and I think
what we've seen over the last few days is nothing short of
stunning. I hope you'll take that inspiration, and the need to work
together, with you, and I hope you'll take with you one other thing,
which is a deep sense of responsibility of what it means to be on the
precipice of changing people's lives with cancer.
So thank you for taking that with you, and I'll turn it over to my colleague,
Alice.
Thank you, Paul, and I also wanted to extend my welcome and thanks to all of
you for attending this final plenary session, really to cap
off our annual meeting. Now, like Paul, I think
this week has been just incredible and inspiring.
We had hundreds of scientific sessions, and I think so many
opportunities to learn about the latest advances in
cancer research and medicine.
I know I wasn't able to attend all of the sessions, so I just wanted to remind
everyone that there is an awesome virtual meeting platform,
and that is going to be open. It's already open now, and it'll be open through
October. So I think that's a great way to catch sessions that you may have
missed.
So for this last plenary session, we're really, really fortunate to have
three leading investigators present on highlights and
themes that have emerged during this annual meeting.
And we've asked them to place the findings in the broader context of their
respective fields, and to also give us a sense of where we go
next. And so I'd like to welcome our first
speaker, Dr. Katie Politi,
to the podium. Dr. Politi is the Joseph A. and Lucille K.
Madri Professor of Pathology and Internal Medicine in the Section of Medical
Oncology at the Yale Cancer Center.
Katie is also deputy director of the Cancer
Center, co-director of the Yale Lung Spore, and
co-director of the Center for Thoracic Cancers at Yale.
And Paul and I are very grateful to Katie because she has served on our
annual meeting program committee as well.
So Dr. Politi is going to provide
a summary of highlights, and key
takeaways from basic and translational research
presentations. Katie?
Thank you.
Thank you very much. It is such an honor to be here
today and to tell you about the basic and translational
science highlights of this fantastic meeting.
These are my disclosures. First and foremost, I would like
to thank three amazing scientists who worked with
me to develop this presentation. They are
Daniel Boyarski, a clinical fellow at the Yale Cancer
Center, Mariana do Carmo, an MD PhD student at Yale,
and Rebecca Starble, a Yale School of Medicine science
fellow. They attended sessions, helped develop the
topics, and helped make the slides for this presentation, and I wouldn't
have been able to do this without their partnership.
So thank you very much.
We came up with five main themes and
topics that I'd like to go over today.
The first topic that I'd like to cover is related to artificial
intelligence and cancer. And given that we're in this
beautiful seaside location, we chose some
coastal themes to match up to the different topics that we'll tell you
about throughout the presentation.
So why AI and cancer? Well, if we make a word
cloud of the themes of the presentations from the
2021 meeting, five years ago, for example, there was
nothing in here. You don't see artificial intelligence mentioned.
We did this then for 2026, and you can see how
AI stands out as one of the main topics of the
presentations at this year's annual meeting.
And so
what did we see? Well, we saw presentations on
foundation models for cancer research.
And what were some of the hot areas of foundation model
development related to cancer research?
Well, we saw presentations about how these can be used to
study protein structure, and the relationship with protein structure,
and then binding to different therapies.
You can see an image here from the presentation from Regina Barzilay
about BOLTZ.
Foundation models are being developed also to study single-cell
data, cell perturbation data, digital pathology, spatial
'omics, and longitudinal patient modeling.
It's early days for the development of these foundation models for
cancer research, and so we really have to ensure that we're going
to have adequate diverse training data to
minimize biases, and also
rigorous validation and benchmarking to ensure reliability of the
foundation models. One of the
major places where we really saw the application of artificial
intelligence was to pathology.And
one of the things that emerged in a lot of the talks was really how we can
use H&E slides and
in conjunction with artificial intelligence
and machine learning, and really learn about the molecular
phenotypes of tumors and how these H&E slides then can
actually be used for prognostic and predictive
information gathering. And here's an example from a presentation
from Christina Curtis. You can see here where
if you use slides of estrogen
receptor-positive breast cancer, apply
artificial intelligence models, you could actually then
identify the cases that are more at high risk of recurrence than those that
are at lower risk of recurrence. We also saw many
talks on multimodal approaches, how these can improve the
performance of pathology foundation models, and we see
increasing efforts to build models that allow the prediction of
high-plex spatial data from low-plex
H&Es. We'll see these used much more going
forward. And of course, this provides the opportunity for
democratizing precision oncology.
What about agentic AI? Well, we're
beginning to see presentations on how we can use AI as a
co-scientist
to design experiments, to generate hypotheses, to analyze
biological data, including, for example, here,
AI utilizing data then to predict responses
to immunotherapy. And you can see here different agents used
applied to these data sets, some with more success than others in
predicting immunotherapy responses.
So this is a very rapidly evolving field.
And I think we'll see these tools used increasingly both in academia and in
industry. And of course,
again, we're going to have to be very careful about appropriate
benchmarking in these cases.
So the other topic that I'd like to cover is really
related to novel therapeutic modalities and
targets.
There are some really new creative drugs that are being developed,
and this really emerged in the presentations
during this annual meeting. Before I go to talk
about some of those
new modalities, I did want to touch a little bit on
KRAS, because if you look at this AI word cloud, I
just told you about how we're learning so much about AI.
It's developing really quickly. But if we look at our word cloud for
2026, KRAS is really little in this word cloud.
And I have to say, I think it felt from the
conversations and the presentations and what we're seeing, that it should have been
much bigger in the word cloud. And so I'm going to jump ahead
and tell you a little bit why is that?
Well,
one of the things that we've seen is that in the past decade, we've seen the
emergence of many KRAS inhibitors, many RAS inhibitors,
mutant selective ones, pan RAS inhibitors, pan KRAS
inhibitors. And you can see a list of
these here in clinical development shown on the right.
And so hand in hand with the development of all
of these inhibitors, there's a ton of science that is happening and the
science that is happening really to further understand the
biology of RAS-driven tumors. And here I'm highlighting the
identification of a master regulator transcription factor
in KRAS driven pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma that
really contributes to a hypoxic phenotype and EMT in these
tumors. So lots of biology happening.
At the same time, a lot of preclinical work to really
understand what are the types of approaches and combinatorial
approaches, especially, that we need to be thinking about and using
in combination with RAS inhibitors to prevent or overcome drug
resistance. And we heard a lot of examples of those.
And also examples of the biology of adaptive resistance.
What are some of the changes that we see in tumors when you start
treating with a KRAS inhibitor? And for example, in this
example shown here, upregulation of receptor tyrosine kinase is on
the surface that then potentially could be used in
conjunction with antibody drug conjugates that are targeting them.
And then we're also beginning to understand molecular and transcriptional
subtypes and how these can impact
responses to RAS inhibitors. So I think a lot more to come in this
area going forward. We have new agents that are continuously being developed.
RAS degraders, for example, molecules that disrupt RAS and
PI3 kinase
interactions. So a lot more to see going
forward.
Some of the other things that really emerged from
the
presentations at this meeting related to new therapies are that there's
really a, I'd say, booming of proximity-inducing
therapies, including protein degraders and molecular
glues. And I think we had seen a lot of
PROTACs being developed, the degrader therapies over the years.
Now what we're seeing are these proximity-inducing therapies that can
cause transcriptional repression, protein
relocalization, protein stabilization.
They can have gain-of-function activities, and you can see some
examples of these shown below. So we're really seeing a shift
more towards proximity pharmacology.
And this could allow us to more fine-tune some of the therapeutic
effects of drugs with some of these often bifunctional
molecules.
We
also have seen many advances in the field of antibody
drug conjugates. And soI think one of the
things that we saw in a lot of the presentations were some of the work that
is happening to go beyond the classical antibody drug conjugates
and further thinking of how we can develop those more.
We've seen immune-stimulating ADCs, precision
degrader antibody drug conjugates.
We see an expansion to diverse payloads beyond
chemotherapy payloads. We've also seen constructs being
developed that have dual payloads.
And then there's work that is happening and that we saw presented to understand
the mechanisms of resistance to these antibody drug conjugates,
whether they be alterations in the target, the payload.
And then what is the effect of levels of the target on the sensitivity to
these therapies? Looking ahead, I think we're going to
see a lot more work to really understand mechanisms of resistance
to antibody drug conjugates and the development of rational
combinations with these agents, but also other therapies
like radioligand therapies, for which there were sessions here, and I think we're
going to see that further develop in the future.
Well, what about cancer immunotherapies and new
immunotherapeutic approaches?
CAR therapies have had quite a bit of success in
hematological malignancies and have had more limited
efficacy to date, at least in solid tumors.
We see a lot of work pointing in the direction of trying to figure
out how to use these in solid tumors.
And some examples of what is happening are examples
of, for example, could we use CARs to target
and reprogram an immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment?
And there was an example of an anti-FAP CAR T
approach to sort of remodel the microenvironment in a solid
tumor and then making it easier for other therapies to
function. Technologies are expanding beyond T cells
to CARs for NK cells, for example, and dendritic cells, and
also AI being used to improve the design of engineered
T-cell receptors for antigen recognition.
So I think looking ahead, I think we're really at the
forefront of really starting to think of how we can use
methods for CAR delivery directly in vivo, and I think that's
something that we'll see develop further in coming years.
We also saw many presentations on
vaccines and how we can leverage and use vaccines
for cancer therapy. I think we're really learning a
little bit more about how cancer vaccines can be used, what the
effects are on the immune system of cancer vaccines, how these
might differ from some of the immune checkpoint inhibitors.
Also, how we can use vaccines to augment responses to
immune checkpoint inhibitor therapies,
and how this functions, in part at least, through activating the
immune system. And then there was some work presented on how cancer vaccines
may also enhance the efficacy of adoptive cell
therapies, and that's shown in this example in a melanoma model
here. There are lots of open questions, but I think that this is just
going to be an area where we're going to see tremendous expansion and growth
in the coming years. So I really look forward
to seeing how this field develops.
Well, with all of these therapies, with new therapies, with older
therapies, we unfortunately have the problem of drug resistance and of
minimal residual disease. And so
we saw that this is an area of
emphasis for many investigators in the field.
We saw a session, opening plenary session, that really set
the groundwork for where we
are in our understanding of minimal residual disease and really pointed
out how there are two types of minimal residual disease, the persister
cells that are left over after
systemic treatment, and that give
rise to the resistant state, and then also the situation in
which you have micrometastatic disease that is present after
local therapy. So kind of two different settings.
When thinking about the first setting, we saw presentations on
the biology of this minimal residual disease, of these persister
cells, and how the persister cells can co-opt
different injury repair states and
interact with cells in the microenvironment that help them survive and
give rise to the resistant state. We also learned that
plasticity of the minimal residual disease is
really an important component of that state, and so that
heterogeneity is really challenging.
And
in one of the presentations, there's sort of a forward-looking presentation by
Chris Marine about how maybe we could take these cells and
direct them to a certain state with a specific type of
treatment. And then maybe we can use other approaches, and he proposed to
use a morphometric approach based on cell surface area and volume
to really select the cells and then target those cells.
So some things to think about. In the context of
micrometastatic disease present after local therapy, for
example, I think we're really in early
stages of learning about the potential of ctDNA and
how ctDNA-informed decisions can actually be used to
escalate and deescalate therapy.
There are a lot of nuances here, different situations for
different cancer types and for different therapies that are being used.
So I think there's a lot of work to do there.
We also saw that some of the approaches now
that we can use for monitoring circulating tumor DNA are
really advancing, and even the potential of using plasma whole
genome sequencing for MRD monitoring that was talked
about by Dan Landau in his plenary
presentation. WellWhat about resistance?
And one of the areas where there's a lot of work that
is happening currently is really understanding this plasticity
that happens as tumors become resistant to therapy.
And this is very daunting because there isn't a specific
mutation, for example, that the cells are dependent on, or things that we
can think of targeting easily. But what we're beginning to learn is we're
beginning to learn about the pathways and the processes
that really can
determine the phenotype of a specific
tumor at resistance. And Charles Sawyers talked about the
involvement of YAP/TEAD, Notch, and androgen receptor
signaling in determining in prostate cancer whether tumors
will have an adenocarcinoma phenotype or go down a
neuroendocrine route. And with that knowledge,
then we also can think of therapeutically targeting the
specific lineages and identifying vulnerabilities of those lineages.
Other data that is emerging is really on
the biology of this plasticity. Why is it that there are some
situations in which tumors can kind of take these different route?
Why aren't they constrained in the way that one would expect them to be?
And there was work from Dr. Posovich showing how SMARCA4
deficiency really allows and enables a cell state
disorder and promotes sort of random transitions between
transcriptional states. And this, as you can imagine, can make it very
difficult to figure out how to treat the tumor because
it can take different routes and be very aggressive.
And so all of this knowledge is really going to help us
identify novel targets for specific lineage states in the future.
So
I'd like to move on to the fourth topic, which is the cancer
genome. And when we think of the cancer genome, I think one of the
things that really has come out of the meeting this year is that we have
the opportunity with some of the ways in which we can probe
the genome to really get better insight into chromosomal
instability and structural variants.
And in particular, this comes from the fact that now we have very
rich whole-genome sequencing data sets.
And just to point out, there's been an expansion of
TCGA data, whole-genome sequencing data,
deep sequencing of 8,500 tumor normal
pairs that are now downloadable. And there's also been the development
of bioinformatic tools to be able to study these
data sets, whole-genome sequencing data, and really understand structural
variants in these data. This is really important
because with this information then, we can start to
understand how these structural variants are related to different
treatments and different treatment modalities.
And it's going to help us in the future really understand tumor
evolution and cancer drivers, again, both
of which have implications for how we treat tumors.
So last but not least, I'd like to tell you
about some of the work on the tumor micro and the tumor macro
environments that was covered at this meeting.
For sure, I will not do this topic justice, but I'm going to talk about
a couple of different things that emerged.
First of all,
we saw a lot of presentations and a lot of research
to understand immune evasion. And this is really important
because to be able to deploy immune checkpoint blockade and other
cancer immunotherapies, we need to understand mechanisms
of immune evasion.
We see deep and rigorous work into
understanding the biology of T cells through
treatment with immune checkpoint inhibitors.
And in a presentation from John Wherry, we saw an
analysis, for example, of the T cells showing that maybe
continuous treatment with PD-1 isn't the best because we don't have
those most functional T cells there anymore.
And so maybe we need to think of other approaches to treat with
anti-PD-1 therapy to maximize the functionality of
T cells. We saw also some work in pediatric
brain tumors in a very interesting
way in which the tumor can actually mediate
immunosuppression through the CSF, the
cerebrospinal fluid, essentially leading to
an expansion of hematopoietic stem cell progenitor cells
in the skull, and that then in the tumor microenvironment, these
become immunosuppressive MDSCs and Tregs.
And so you create that immunosuppressive microenvironment.
But figuring out that pathway and that loop can help
interrupt it so that then we can get other
therapies to work better. And also we saw
presentations in the context of hematological malignancies on how
we can leverage epigenetic processes and epigenetic
priming
to really help
work in conjunction then with different types of T cell immunotherapies.
So that's kind of a direction in which
some of that work is going.
I'd also like to highlight how there are new technologies that allow
us to study immune evasion. Cathy Wu showed an approach called
Slide and Go Tag, in which you can
examine the T cell state, TCR neoantigen
localization, and much more in the tumor microenvironment
on a single slide. And so that can be very powerful
for us to really gain more insight into
mechanisms of immune evasion.We know that
cancer is a systemic disease, and we know there
were presentations on cachexia, presentations on
processes like metabolic disorders.
One of the things that I'd like to point out that I think is really
maturing right now in the field and really coming to the forefront is our
understanding of the interaction between the
nervous system and cancer. And in particular, the nervous system
and how this affects the immune system and cancer.
This is kind of challenging because what I learned is that when you're
thinking of the nervous system, nerve endings are in tumors,
but the nerve cell body is not. So you actually need to
develop approaches in which you can trace the nerves and
identify the nerves that innervate an organ or a tissue so that then
you can study what are the molecular features of those nerves
in a tumor situation versus a normal tissue.
And that was presented here. And also, we're learning
that other cells that one might not think of necessarily
as cells that would produce neurotransmitters can do this.
And we saw work showing that, for example, T cells and B cells can
produce neurotransmitters like acetylcholine.
Who would have thought that? And the
fact that they can produce the acetylcholine is very important for regulating the
tumor immune microenvironment. So where are we heading from
this? Well, there's a vast complexity of neurotransmitters and their
receptors. And so there's a ton of work to be done to really
tease out this complexity and understand the role of
the nervous system in cancer.
So there are many factors that influence
cancer phenotypes, and I'd like to close on this.
So
there were many presentations about genetic determinants, environmental
exposures, aging, the microbiome, and stress.
I'm just going to touch on some of the information that we learned from
aging. We know that aging is the biggest risk factor
associated with cancer, and
specific cancer phenotypes are really associated with aging.
And so we saw a lot of presentations that really showed us that the
stroma,
aged stroma, can modulate the tumor microenvironment.
Clonal hematopoiesis, it's not passive.
It can affect tumor phenotypes directly.
Responses and the effects of chemotherapy and
therapeutic agents are different in aged mice compared to young mice.
And then we're learning about the biology of tumors that
are associated with aging. And in this presentation, there was a
presentation about SPEN and NOTCH2 mutant diffuse large cell
B-cell lymphomas. These are associated with increased age.
But in the studies, they also found that the tumors are more aggressive in females.
And so there's a whole other layer of
study to really understand why are these more aggressive in females
than in males. And so I think looking ahead, a very important thing is going to
be to use models and systems that really better reflect and take into
account age, whether this is early, young
age, or old age.
So with that, I'm going to close this wrap-up.
I would like to thank
Corria Batijn, Michaela Eggeblad, and Sheila Stewart, who gave
this presentation in years past. They shared their slides, their
presentations, and their wisdom with me, and that was really helpful.
I'd also like to really thank Marge, Lillian, Alice, Paul,
Lisa, Elena, and all of the AACR staff for the
opportunity to give this presentation.
And also, when I was thinking of the motto
of this meeting, which is Precision, Partnership,
Purpose,
a word that I'd like to add, another P that I'd like to add to
this when I think about all of you, is passion.
You brought passion to this AACR
annual meeting. So thank you very much to that.
Thank you to all the presenters who shared slides and information.
And deep apologies to those whose work I wasn't able
to cover, even if you sent me slides. I'm so sorry.
There's so much amazing information that was presented
here. I'd just like to take one final minute
with a very personal reflection.
Three years ago, I was diagnosed with estrogen
receptor-positive, early-stage breast cancer.
And it is really thanks to the precision,
the partnership, the purpose, and the passion of the cancer
research community that, as I can say, I can live my best
life today. I've benefited from all of the science that
has led to the identification of breast cancer subtypes.
I actually met an AACR member, a
50-plus-year AACR member, who developed the IHC
assays for estrogen receptor the other day here.
How cool is that?
Benefited from the
gene expression profiling, all the studies that led to that, that could
determine whether I needed chemotherapy or not.
So it's really all of the cancer research community that is
making, I think, what sometimes seems impossible, totally
possible. And so I know that I'm going back home inspired,
Paul, as you were saying, and excited, and so hopeful, and I
can't wait to see what we do in the years to come as a community.
So thank you very much.
Thank you, Dr. Politi.
That was masterful.
And thank you for sharing your personal story.
You're an inspiration.You also
provide an opportunity here to show the breadth of the
science in that. And I think a huge credit goes to the
program committee, who's worked tirelessly this year and
championed certain areas and put in time to develop sessions.
We're very grateful to them for what they've actually done.
So, as your last slide indicated, cancer doesn't happen in
cells, just. It happens in people.
And people live in environments. They do things. They eat. They walk around.
And this is an area that we are watching remarkable
progress, and that leads to our next speaker,
Dr. Christopher Li. So he's going to be speaking about
prevention, early detection, population sciences, and disparities research, and
what we've learned at the meeting. Dr.
Li is the Vice President for Faculty Development at the Fred Hutchinson Cancer
Center, the Associate Director for Faculty Development for the Fred
Hutchinson-University of Washington Seattle Children's Cancer Consortium, and
he holds the Helen G. Edison Endowed Chair for Breast Cancer
Research at the Fred Hutchinson Cancer Center. Dr.
Li also served on the AACR Annual Meeting Program Committee.
Let's welcome Dr. Li.
Good afternoon, everyone. I want to start by thanking Lillian,
Paul, and Alice for this really tremendous opportunity to share with you all the
highlights related to cancer prevention, early detection, population
sciences, and disparities research from this conference. Also want to thank Dr.
Marge Foti for encouraging me to do this, as well as Dr.
Scarlett Lin Gomez, who gave this presentation last year and shared her
wisdom with me. I don't have any
disclosures. And so as an epidemiologist, I love to count
things, and so I thought it would be helpful to start by just giving you a quick
snapshot of all of the science that was presented here under the broad umbrella of
population sciences, which spanned yesterday's outstanding
plenary session on early-onset cancers to over 50 talks
in major symposia or advances in sessions, along with more than
600 abstracts. So you may wonder how I was able to attempt
to cover all of this incredible depth and breadth of programming, and I am
very happy to disclose that I did not use AI at all in the development of this
presentation. But I was very lucky to have stellar support
from two trainees. Both of them received awards here at the annual
meeting and presented their science as well.
Kaylee, who is a postdoc working with me at Fred Hutch, and Vicky, who is a
graduate student at the Huntsman Cancer Institute.
And what I will present to you
now really would not have been possible without their incredible support.
So thank you both for your contributions.
I also took the strategy of asking many of my colleagues if they would send me a
summary of their talk to include in this presentation, and so I want to
thank the many people who sent me those materials.
So many, in fact, that I couldn't ultimately use them all just due to time
restrictions and just want to recognize that this talk is really just scratching
the surface of all of the outstanding science in these fields that were
presented at this conference.
So just to give you an overview of this presentation, I'm going to describe some of
the exciting results that were shared across the very broad spectrum of population
science, which begins with thinking about primary prevention and etiology,
next to screening, early detection, and interception, and then treatment and
survivorship. At this year's meeting, we also identified some
predominant crosscutting themes
that I'll also integrate, and these related to AI, health
equity, and disparities, as well as community engagement.
So I'm going to start with primary prevention.
And with respect to this field, we do know a lot of different things that people
can do to prevent cancer, yet there's so much work that we still need to do.
And so I thought that a question that kind of unified a lot of the talks in this
space were, how can we leverage things like commonly used
medications, diet, interventions in high-risk
populations, and even policy to prevent cancer?
So I think a great place to start is the plenary session that was chaired by Dr.
Chan yesterday, focused on early-onset cancers.
In his wonderful talk, Dr. Chan reviewed the recent progress in our
understanding of the etiology of early-onset colorectal cancer that
included evidence linking early life obesity, insulin
resistance, and even prenatal exposures that increase colorectal
cancer risk, suggesting that risk is really accumulating across a lifetime
and may begin with exposures that happen before birth.
One specific finding from his talk that I'm highlighting here is his
characterization of ultra-processed foods as a novel risk factor for
early-onset colorectal cancer. He used data from the Nurses Health Study
II
cohort, where he identified that those in the top two
quartiles of ultra-processed food consumption had about
50% higher risk of early-onset colorectal adenomas.
Unfortunately, we know that children are starting to consume these
unhealthy foods at very young ages.
So it's important to clarify what are the specific components of these foods that
contribute to risk, as well as the underlying biological
mechanisms. Another fascinating talk from this plenary was
from Dr. Chadeayne, who presented combined evidence from both mouse and human
studies relevant to postpartum breast cancer, which is a type of breast
cancer associated with a particularly poor survival and carries high
rates of liver metastasis. She presented her team's novel
findings, showing that given that the liver plays an important role in supporting
lactation, weaning triggers liver involution and actually
can promote a liver pre-metastatic niche.
So a summary of her talk was really that postpartum breast cancer warrants
increased surveillance, treatment escalation, and targeted prevention and
treatment strategies that really take into account this underlying
involution biology.Another
engaging session was this one that focused on how can we
translate epidemiology to the clinic, and this one focused on
aspirin. So it is very well established that aspirin reduces risk of
colorectal cancer and other GI cancers by 30% through a number of
different mechanisms, but there are a number of unanswered questions in this field.
Dr. Langley described her work identifying that reducing
platelet activation is one of aspirin's key anticancer
effects, and so this has led her to try to pursue this question of
can we use this information to identify which patients will
benefit the most from aspirin? She's currently evaluating a
biomarker, UTXM, which is a biomarker of platelet
activation, to see if this can inform who will versus who will not
respond to aspirin, and she's evaluating this in the ADD ASPIRIN trial
of cancer patients. Next, Dr. Yilmaz
described something that I had never heard about before, which is a
recently observed paradox that while aspirin has been shown to
improve survival when given to Stage 1 to 3 colorectal cancer
patients, it actually has the opposite effect and reduces
survival when given to Stage 4 patients.
And he presented
very exciting unpublished work exploring what are the underlying biological
mechanisms of this paradox. And then lastly, in this session, Dr.
Dubois presented his large body of work
showcasing the prostaglandin E2 effects on immune
cell biology. And as you can see in the graph here, delivery of
celecoxib resulted in a number of changes to immune cells in the
microenvironment.
In another talk, Dr. Stone described the potential of a different type of
intervention, in this case, a surgical intervention, as a strategy to prevent
ovarian cancer. This approach is based on recent evidence
that most ovarian cancers actually originate in the fallopian tube,
not in the ovary itself. So salpingectomy could be
used to prevent ovarian cancer. And actually, there was a study published just last
month that it can reduce risk of serous ovarian cancer
by 80%. However, uptake of salpingectomy in the US remains
low, and there are persistent disparities.
So to address this, Dr. Stone's team has focused on identifying
what are the barriers to receiving this type of intervention, and she
identified that insurance coverage and inadequate patient education were
the primary barriers. In response to this,
her team has developed the Outsmart Ovarian Cancer Collaborative.
They've developed a comprehensive curriculum that addresses the structural and
educational barriers, and she's in the process of developing a multi-site
trial that will look at the acceptability, feasibility, and safety
of opportunistic salpingectomy, which could have tremendous impact on
reducing ovarian cancer.
And then the last
thing that I'll talk about related to cancer prevention was this very interactive
forum that was focused on exploring policy solutions.
So the panel here included multiple experts who
focused on how policy solutions can have a meaningful impact on cancer
prevention. The panel really focused primarily on lung cancer and
highlighted how strong regulatory frameworks have meaningfully
curbed tobacco use and that there are these emerging challenges,
such as the introduction of e-cigarettes, but that policy, again, here, can have an
important role. The graph that's shown here indicates
use of e-cigarettes
among youth and children, and when policy was implemented, shown on the
red line, very quickly after that, you see a sharp drop in the
use of e-cigarettes among children, just demonstrating the power
of policy.
They also spent quite a bit of time talking about the role of lung
cancer screening. It's a very effective strategy, but we could do even
better. They talked about how we could avert an additional 88,000 lung
cancers in the United States in the next five years if we were able to broaden the
criteria and accessibility of lung cancer screening.
So this session really just highlighted how policy solutions are a
necessary step for realizing many of the benefits
of our prevention and screening efforts.
So I'll now turn to cancer screening.
I think we all recognize that when done well, cancer screening saves
lives, but there are certain issues with cancer screening that we're grappling
with. One is that we're still largely using a one-size-fits-all approach for
cancer screening. Overdiagnosis and overtreatment can be persistent
issues. We also can miss aggressive cancers by screening,
and there are many types of cancers where we still don't have a useful screening
test. So I think an overarching question here that many of the talks
tried to address is, can we make cancer screening both more
efficacious and more efficient through implementing risk-based
precision screening? And also, are there new screening tools that could be
impactful?
So I think in order to realize the promise of precision screening, we need
accurate models that can be used to inform who should be screened and
how frequently they should be screened. And Dr.
Song presented his work on the potential benefits of risk-based screening
for colorectal cancer. He's developed a risk score to guide
subsequent screening among those who've just had a negative screening
colonoscopy.
As shown in this figure, the risk that high-risk patients,
based on this score, have 10 years after their negative colonoscopy
is only reached after 25 years among the low-risk
patients, suggesting that the low-risk patients likely don't
need to receive a repeat screening colonoscopy for
maybe even more than a decade after those who are high risk.
However, he recognized that the existing models require further improvement,
and he is integrating use of AI as well as electronic health
record data to try and improve model performance and achieve
clinical utility.A fascinating talk
was this one given by Dr. Plon, who shared her work on the
development of newborn screening that incorporates testing for genetic
variants that are relevant to pediatric cancer.
She described that we, in the US, do universal screening for over 50
conditions in newborns, but none of these screens include
screening for cancer. And this is despite evidence to
suggest that newborn screening could reduce cancer death before age 20
by 8%.
And she described a retrospective study from Michigan, which found that
7% of pediatric cancers could be detected by screening,
including 80% of bilateral retinoblastomas, and that's what's shown in the
graph here. So her and her team are in the process of establishing
additional prospective data to support what she envisions as
a large-scale clinical trial that will use an ultra-low-cost
pooled targeting sequencing pipeline that, if ultimately
implemented, has the potential to prevent pediatric cancer deaths.
And then, the last vignette I will describe related to cancer screening is
this also quite interesting talk by Dr.
Ayala, who is a computer scientist.
He described how his work is focused on three goals.
One, using available data to better inform patient disease status.
Two, developing new guidelines, risk models, and algorithms
with these data. And three, really proving that the AI models
work. So his team has developed what they're calling Pillar Zero,
which is a free next generation foundation model applied
to radiology that he has shown outperforms
all of its competitors. And basically what this approach does is that it can be
applied to any type of imaging data.
He gave examples of abdominal and pelvic CTs as well as
chest CTs. And basically, you can use this model to say, "In this
CT scan, is there evidence of a pancreatic tumor?
Is there evidence of a prostate cancer?" And so he's continuing to work to
refine these models, again, towards ultimate clinical
utility.
So, I'll now turn to the area of early detection.
There's certainly a lot of evidence to support the promise of early
detection, but this field is hampered by many challenges that are outlined
here. And so I think a common question that presentations in this
space ought to address is how do we overcome these challenges in the field of
early detection to realize its potential to reduce the burden of
cancer? Obviously, a very hot topic, our multi-cancer early detection
tests.
Probably many of you in the room read this article in "The New York Times" from a
few months ago, which reported the failure of the
GRAIL multi-cancer early detection test to reach its clinical utility
endpoints. And so this forum that was held last night was a very
interactive session that focused on what is the state of where we are
now, how do we take stock of the results that have
come out, and how can we potentially realize the hope of this
strategy? So there was a great panel of three experts in this
field who really range from those who maintain
very high enthusiasm for the promise of MCEDs to those who remain actually quite
skeptical about their ultimate potential utility.
There was, I think, some agreement that these tests do have
promise and that promise is real, but that we need to make sure that when we're
evaluating them, we're using rigorous study designs, and that we're also
very clearly and transparently communicating their benefits and
harms to the public. There was a recognition that the harms of these tests
are also real, at both the individual and population levels, but also that
there is an urgency here. We want to try to be able to detect cancer early
to save lives, and we don't want to have to wait another 10 to 15 years for the
next set of trials to be complete. And so how do we balance that sense of
urgency with the need for rigor? And so I think there
is a lot of promise, I think, still in the space, but, obviously
caution in how we move forward. While obviously a lot of
interest in multi-cancer tests, there are also many people
still working on single site early detection strategies.
And I'm highlighting this talk from Dr.
Simeone, who recognized that we've made very little progress in
improving the dismal survival rates that pancreatic cancer patients currently
face.
Early detection of pancreas cancer remains an important priority,
and it holds promise in that we know that the five-year survival rate for
Stage 1A pancreas cancers is actually 84%.
So in order to address this gap, Dr.
Simeone talked about the PRECEDE study, which is the world's largest
longitudinal study of individuals at high risk for pancreas
cancer. There are over 65 participating
institutions. They're trying to recruit 20,000 patients.
And they're doing germline testing as well as performing image-based screening.
So far, she presented very promising results.
Seventy-two percent of the screen-detected lesions were Stage 1,
which is much better than we see in the general population.
And really that this PRECEDE study could be an invaluable resource
for testing and validating promising early detection strategies that are
now emerging for pancreas cancer.
So now I'll turn to cancer interception.
This was actually a very hot topic at this meeting.
So for those who are not fully familiar with what cancer interception means,
it's really the idea that we can identify and
then treat early pre-cancerous lesions to prevent them from
ultimately becoming cancer. So the poster child for interception is
colonoscopy and the removal of adenomas and polyps.
By taking out those pre-cancerous lesions, we are
intercepting the development of future cancers.
So a question here across cancer interception talks was
what are emerging opportunities to reduce the burden of cancer through cancer
interception?There was a great talk given by my colleague, Dr.
Nora Disis, on the promise of vaccines in this space.
And she talked about the fact that vaccines can induce memory that lasts
decades, T cells can be specific to particular targets with limited
toxicity, and that they can also travel to any type of disease.
And she gave an overview of many of the different current vaccine
trials, Phase I and II studies in Lynch syndrome patients,
as well as for DCIS,
which in early results show immunogenicity and early efficacy
with minimal adverse events. So this figure that she had in her
talk really, I think, shows what her vision is for a
near-term future where we're able to use cancer-related vaccines
for
primary prevention as prophylactics,
for interception, as well as to prevent future recurrences.
So I think really a very exciting
time in the area of cancer vaccines.
I think also critical to the field of interception is identifying
promising targets for interception. And Dr.
Lee presented just
very elegant work that employs innovative genetically engineered mouse
models, patient-derived samples, and multi-omic profiling to
identify mechanistic drivers for early-onset basal-like
triple-negative breast cancer, to identify opportunities for
early interception that was quite exciting to see.
And then lastly, with respect to interception, is this example from Dr.
Drapkin, whose work is in ovarian cancer.
Again, recognizing that high-grade serous ovarian cancer
arises in the fallopian tube, there are these early lesions, so-called
STIC lesions, that have variable clinical risk.
So the translational goal of Dr. Drapkin's work is to try to define
early genomic and microenvironmental features of these lesions that
could then enable both early detection and interception.
And so he's using multimodal spatial
strategies on these tubal precursors and
he presented quite robust data showing that
early lesions show parallel genomic and immune
trajectories, providing, I think, a promising framework
for risk stratification and interception.
The next topic I'm going to cover is cancer disparities.
Really could have picked any cancer to highlight persistent disparities that exist
here in the United States. This is just colorectal cancer incidence and mortality.
And I think a common question here is what are the emerging
opportunities to meaningfully reduce these longstanding cancer
disparities? And I think a great place to start
is this year's honoree for the AACR Minorities in
Cancer Research Jane Cooke Wright Award, which recognizes outstanding
contributors to the field of cancer disparities.
With his H-index of 169, Dr.
Jemal, this year's awardee, is truly among the most influential voices in
oncology. And in his lecture, he provided numerous
examples of how cancer surveillance data can promote cancer
prevention and control. And the one that I will highlight here
is his recent paper in "Cancer Discovery" demonstrating the powerful
impact that legislation and policy can have on reducing cancer
disparities. So what he showed here is that compared to cancer
patients in states without Medicaid expansion, those with
Medicaid expansion experienced substantial improvements in
overall survival in their most vulnerable populations, including
rural and high-poverty communities and among non-Hispanic Black
patients. So I think this makes it very clear that the current threat that we
have of rolling back support for healthcare in our country could have
a devastating effect on curtailing and even reversing the progress that we
have made in recent years.
Another highly engaging session, I think a lot of the participants had a lot of
fun with this one, presented the state-of-the-art in leveraging
geospatial tools, methods, and data to address issues related
to cancer incidence, outcomes, and disparities.
These approaches are now being actively used to identify cancer
hotspots, determine drivers of geographic disparities, and also to
inform public health policies. So to just give a few examples, Dr.
Hardt showcased her work on using machine learning to
measure neighborhood features such as access to green space.
Dr. Cheng
talked about her work on developing and disseminating racial and
ethnic-specific measures of structural racism relevant to
cancer. And Dr. Vo Pham presented very
exciting work that she has done to integrate
175 different neighborhood-level
variables, things that span air pollution,
cancer screening rates, social determinants of health, that are
now all publicly available through an open source geospatial
web app, and I encourage you to check this out through the QR code shown
here. But it really has the potential to impact our understanding of
geospatial elements that are related to cancer.
Another barrier to our current approach to cervical cancer screening
is that it requires collections to be performed by a healthcare
provider. And so we heard the results from the SHIP
trial, which is led by NCI and was presented by Dr.
Gera, that evaluated the performance of self-collected vaginal
sampling for cervical cancer screening.
And while the sensitivity of the self-sampling versus the clinical collection was a
little bit lower, it was still quite high for both CIN2
and CIN3 grade lesions and higher.
And this has actually paved the way for FDA approval.
You may have seen the article that was just published in "The Cancer Letter" about
this, where we now have the first home assay for cervical cancer
screening, and this will be particularly beneficial for women living in areas with
limited access to
healthcare.And then I also want to
highlight this work.
We recognize that several regions of Africa display a disparate
number of prostate cancer cases and deaths, but there is no tailored
care for this population. And so Dr.
Argos presented just phenomenal work from the Health Equity
Research and Outcomes Improvement Consortium, Prostate Cancer Precision Health
Africa 1K, so a very long collaborative
resource that aims to identify regional
specific factors that contribute to the higher mutational burden of
prostate cancer in African men.
Two of the key results that she presented are associations between geographic
area and unique prostate cancer genomic subtypes, as well
as in blood metal concentrations.
A major emphasis of this talk was the potential of really
leveraging genomic and exposomic science together to
integrate environmental features with genetic and tumor information to
ultimately reduce prostate cancer incidence and improve survival.
The last area that I'm going to cover is advances in
community outreach and engagement,
where here the question is: how do we meaningfully advance bi-directional
engagement with the communities we serve to expand our
impact?
A really great talk was given by Dr.
Wetter, who presented on his common sense framework to
create and sustainably maintain community partnerships with the goal to
create mutually beneficial long-term solutions and maximize the health
benefits to larger populations. He really distilled this down to three key
elements. One, always addressing and focusing on partner
priorities. Two, leveraging and respecting the expertise of
your community partners. And three, always designing projects with
long-term sustainability in mind.
Using this framework, he's had tremendous success across the five-state
Mountain West region that he works in, with over $55
million in funding for programs that are driving risk
factor reductions as well as improving access to cancer screening
across this diverse, largely rural population.
And then the last vignette I'm going to share is this one from Dr.
Baez Conde-Garbanati, who described innovative work that her team
is leading to use storytelling to promote cancer communication.
Motivating this work is that about 90% of Americans
struggle to understand complicated health information, and this
presents a major barrier to cancer prevention and
care. Storytelling has been shown to be a highly effective
way of cutting through this complexity, and this research has focused on
pairing storytelling with AI. So the team has
developed the Artificial Intelligence and Community Translation framework, where
AI is blended with authentic participant storytelling to deliver
culturally tailored messages to high-risk communities.
So here's an image of one of these messages where the AI-generated Auntie
Rose is talking to her friend Clara about colorectal cancer
screening. And this team has shown that this approach can amplify patient
voices and can effectively convey cancer information, and they're now
working on producing education materials that are optimized to
reach high-risk, hard-to-reach populations.
So before I end, I just want to give a shout-out to all of the many posters,
again, over 600 across the different areas that I'm covering in this
talk. This area of the exhibit hall was always a very lively one with
all of our population science colleagues.
So just want to recognize all of the work that they presented.
And then just wanted to end with a very quick summary.
So hopefully you can see through this presentation that this is actually an
incredible time to be a population scientist.
I know that we're all struggling with the various headwinds that we're facing in
our world today.
But I think what we saw was just so much exciting work where
we're integrating advances in multi-omic technologies,
AI, data science, and clinical medicine, pairing these
with best practices in community engagements, all to have a
positive impact across the full cancer continuum from primary
prevention to survivorship. It was also, I think, very exciting to
see that many lines of research here are advancing towards
trials that we hope, in future meetings, will
describe near-term clinical and public health impact.
So thank you so much for your attention and the opportunity to give this
presentation.
So thank you, Dr. Flowers, for such a
clear integration and synthesis of the work that's going
on in this exciting area and for highlighting the developments, which are
quite exciting, pointing out the opportunities and the challenges that are ahead
of us. Really beautiful work.
Our last speaker of the session is Dr.
Kathy Dombrowsk, who's going to be talking about clinical research and
clinical trials. It's gratifying to see the continuum
between fundamental mechanistic science through diagnostics, drug
development, to early phase clinical trials.
That's happening here at AACR. It's an
extraordinary ecosystem, and we're going to hear about some of the most
exciting work from that area. Dr. Dombrowsk.
Thank you so much for the kind introduction.
It's such an honor to be here and to highlight the
most important clinical trials presented.
Before I start, I want to really thank my
Clinical Trials Committee co-chair, Dr.
Jayesh Desai, and Dr. Lillian Hsu, for
all their support. And I want to, like my previous
presenters, I want to apologize for not
including the slides that many presenters sent
because of time. But we are really experiencing such an
incredible time in clinical research.And
here are my disclosures.
And so let's start by looking at the themes of
this AACR and clinical trials.
I will second what Dr. Politi said, is
that really it's key to
bridge the cancer biology to
meaningful anti-cancer therapies.
There are no other meetings that do better
bridging between basic science and clinical
research. And really, to be able to push
forward clinical research and really
develop better treatments for patients, it is
important for scientists to collaborate with
clinicians and bring discoveries from the bench
side to the bedside and back.
And that is a culture that AACR
has really helped culture,
and because of that, we can see through clinical
trials that we had more than 265
clinical trial abstracts. We had four plenary
sessions, five mini symposiums focused on
clinical trials. And another key theme is focused
around biomarkers. Now, more than half of the
clinical trials presented had biomarkers
either as a selection or as a
biomarker development plan, which is a huge
change in focus and really realizing the
need of this translation between basic
science and clinical research. And we
have seen exceptional advances in precision
oncology. We have seen
more and more focus on ctDNA, on
perioperative strategies, but also advances
in ADCs, in immunotherapy, in cellular
therapies.
And so for you to be able to
follow my talk, I try to break it down into
these five buckets that
focusing first on precision oncology.
And for me, KRAS, it's huge. It's not very
small on
the print, and really it's pushing new frontiers
that before we would have never imagined.
And so first I want to start by highlighting a
presentation that was given by Dr.
Reyes on the zoldonrasib, which is
a KRAS G12D covalent inhibitor,
which forms a tricomplex that binds to the RAS
on G12D protein and blocks the
interaction with RAS and blocks the downstream MAP
kinase signaling.
And
this presentation was focused on
patients with non-small cell lung
cancer who had KRAS G12D mutations
and who received prior immunotherapy and
chemotherapy.
On this slide, you can see the toxicities, and I really
want to point your attention towards the grade 3, which there are
barely none, which is amazing in these 40
patients. Even if these are preliminary results,
the tolerability of this drug is exceptional.
And when we look at the efficacy at this waterfall plot,
that all patients had a decrease in their
tumors or at least stabilization of the tumors.
And when we look at overall response rate of
52%.
And how about the durability of these treatments?
We can see that
the median progression-free survival was almost a
year.
And how about the translation? When we look at
ctDNA,
73% of patients were able to clear
the ctDNA.
And so this is just a snapshot. Why is this
important? Well, first, is because
this is practice-changing.
The overall response rate, the progression-free survival,
they are unquestionably higher than what we see
normally with the docetaxel, with chemotherapy in
patients with lung cancer. And this is such a highly
unmet need. We don't have a KRAS G12D inhibitor,
and with an excellent tolerance with minimal side
effects.
We stay in the KRAS space. And how about
pan-RAS inhibitors? The next
talk that I want to highlight was from Dr.
Wolpin of deraxone rasib
in patients with metastatic pancreatic
adenocarcinoma as first-line treatment in
combination with chemotherapy.
As compared with the zoldonrasib, the deraxone
rasib is binding not just to G12D,
but it's binding to GTP-bound mutant RAS
in G12, G13, and Q61,
as well as wild-type RAS, and is able
to form a tricomplex that will block the
RAF interaction and the downstream
signaling.The
study was in
first-line metastatic pancreatic cancer
patients,
half of these patients did receive chemotherapy in the adjuvant
or locally advanced setting. And they received
the daraxumab,
the RAS inhibitor,
in combination with chemotherapy, which was
gemcitabine and nab-paclitaxel.
Now, when we look at toxicity, it's very different from the previous one that I
showed. That means that 73% of patients did
have severe side effects.
However, as oncologists, we are used to be
able to treat side effects as long as it's
working. But is it working? And the
answer is yes. Look at this waterfall plot.
Very impressive, and with an overall response
rate of 59%, and disease control
rate of 90%.
But why is this important? Pancreatic
cancer treatment did not change in almost 20
years. There are so many advances in many other tumor
types, but in pancreatic cancer, we were not
able to improve the progression-free and overall survival,
which at five years is less than 5%.
And
almost all patients, more than 90%, have
a KRAS mutation. And so this, to
see a drug that works in combination with
chemotherapy in first-line metastatic
pancreatic cancer patients is
really future practice-changing.
And how about monotherapy? Does it work just by itself?
And the answer is yes, and this is a poster that is highlighted,
presented by Dr. O'Reilly, that the same showing a
beautiful waterfall plot. And when we look at toxicity,
better tolerance, and probably the question will be
to identify these patients who require to have the
combination or just monotherapy.
I don't want to move out of the KRAS space yet
because there is a new KRAS G12C
inhibitor.
This is a little bit different from the KRAS
on inhibitors that we talked previously.
The KRAS G12C, they are off
inhibitors.
They bound to the GTP-bound pocket, and
they lock it in an inactive state.
And there are many
KRAS G12C inhibitors with sotorasib and adagrasib
being approved. And there is a new kid on the block,
elacestrant, that was presented
as an oral presentation by Dr. Chou in
patients with non-small cell lung cancer.
And while I will not have time to go over all the details about this study, I
do want to highlight
that this works in patients who had a
prior KRAS G12C inhibitor with
32% achieving a partial
response. And when we look at tolerability,
it seems to be overall well-tolerated with a low
percentage of Grade 3 adverse events.
And how about colorectal cancer and pancreatic cancer?
KRAS G12C, it's less frequent, but it's still present.
And you can see that as a monotherapy in patients with
colorectal cancer, but also in combination with cetuximab,
it showed activity across different dose levels
and also in patients with pancreatic cancer.
This really highlights that having
newer drugs with higher potency and
potentially faster target engagement can lead to
better results also in these tumor types that do not
have approvals of KRAS G12C inhibitors.
And
last in precision oncology, I want to talk
about the combination of
zotorasib and lunlesertib,
which are VE-1 and PKMYT inhibitors,
which really show the nice relationship between the
cancer biology and the translation in the clinic.
FBXW7, we often see it on the
reports as a mutation, but until now, it was
not actionable. Now we know if there is a
mutation there,
that it can lead to cyclin
E1 overexpression. And also
now we will not ignore anymore the cyclin E1
amplifications that we see on the molecular testing
results
because we have a potential matched
treatment combination, which is the VE-1 and the
PKMYT inhibitors. But
before I
get to the results, I just want to
take a moment to look at the science behind this.
And the VE-1 and PKMYT, they are
both acting on the G2M and
really inhibiting the
CDK1 and causing the cell cycle
arrest. And in
tumor types like ovarian cancer and the tumor types that
have cyclin E1 or
FBXW7 alterations,
these can really be very important
targets.And
as a translation of the cancer biology in the
clinic, we can see that in patients with
ovarian cancer, with cycline E1 amplification,
there is an overall response rate of 60% of
the combination of the WE1 and
PKMYT inhibitors.
And overall, with a good tolerance without discontinuation
of the study drugs because of side effects.
Moving to the next big topic, which are ADCs,
I want to highlight three trials, with the first one being a
combination of trastuzumab deruxtecan,
T-DXd, and olaparib. Why is this
important? Again, I'm going back to this relation
between cancer biology and clinical research.
We
know that topoisomerase inhibitors
will
have
a DNA lesion, will create
pockets of DNA lesions, and because of the PARP
inhibition, these can be
really synergistic. And so
to translate that, there were several
attempts. However, because of overlapping toxicities
between PARP inhibitors and topoisomerase
inhibitors,
it has not been feasible. So really looking at
strategies can we do sequentially, and the
timing of combining two drugs is equally important.
And Dr. Lee presented this as an
investigator-initiated trial. And we can see that
the toxicity is really different if
it's given continuously
versus if it's given
sequentially,
and over the day eight to 14 for the olaparib
and day one for the T-DXd.
And when we look at the responses, you can see that
54% of patients achieved a partial
response or complete response.
Why is this important? It's because it really supports
combining TOP1 antibody drug conjugates with PARP
inhibitors and while using an optimized
schedule. And also this is potentially
of interest in tumors that they are 1+,
and
the research is still ongoing
in a phase 2 clinical trial.
Another study that I would like to highlight is an antibody drug
conjugate targeting claudin-6. Claudin-6
is expressed in many tumor types, including ovarian
cancer.
And when we look at the tolerability
of this treatment, we can see that it has
some hematologic toxicity,
and the response rate is very similar to
other antibody drug conjugates, around
50% with topoisomerase inhibitors.
And it really highlights that there is a new
target for patients with ovarian cancer, which is
claudin-6.
The last one that I want to highlight
is the ZW91, the folate receptor
antibody drug conjugate that was presented by Dr.
Larusso, that it is binding to
a distinct epitope of the folate receptor, and
the payload is a topoisomerase inhibitor with
overall good tolerance. And
what I really want to highlight here is that responses
were seen regardless of the level of the folate
receptor expression, and the same for
endometrial cancer, who the majority were very low
expressers.
And so
it's showing that the folate
receptor antibody drug conjugates with topoisomerase
payload that doesn't require a pre-screening
might be a path forward with an overall response
rate of more than 50%.
And the main challenge in ovarian cancer is that there
are so many antibody drug conjugates that they are in
development, and they all have very similar
payloads. So the question will be, how do we choose
which one we pick
for the patient?
And that is a question that unfortunately we don't
have an answer yet, and we hope that in the
future we will have other types of antibody drug
conjugates with other payloads, and
also we will be able to select better
the treatment for these patients.
Moving on to CAR Ts and complex IOs, I
need to highlight the cilta-cel
in patients with high risk smoldering myeloma, which
is a pre-malignancy, but the risk of
converting into multiple myeloma, it's more than
50% at two years. And while there is
an antibody that is FDA approved, which is the
daratumab, the CD39 antibody,
it
requires continuous treatments.
So the question is, can we just do a one-time
treatment, a one-time CAR T, and be
done?And
the preliminary results of this study, the CAR
PRISM, are pointing towards yes,
especially that this is a treatment that was
well-tolerated with no Grade 3 or higher
CRS events.
There were some particular neurotoxicities
that were non-ICANS,
but most of them resolved. And all
patients were able to achieve MRD negativity
at the 15.3 months follow-up.
And also, all patients were able to achieve an
objective response. And so this is really
highlighting that CAR T is moving into
pre-malignancy, and this opens the
door for maybe other cellular therapies in this
space.
I will just add one slide around the
mesothelin CAR Ts that were presented,
and there were three oral presentations with
mesothelin CAR Ts with different constructs.
And unfortunately,
while the responses were disappointing,
Dr. June very nicely highlighted some of the
challenges that we are facing in solid tumors in
targeting mesothelin.
One related to the
microenvironment, and second, around
the T cell exhaustion. And so we do
need to be able to develop better
cellular therapies to overcome these.
How about immunotherapy? For CCR8, which
is really a marker for the Tregs, there was so
much hope that if we are targeting that, that we will be able
to
annihilate the bad guys. But unfortunately,
two of the trials that were presented
had disappointing results with
response
rate in single digits.
And I really want to pause here and
just to mention that there should not be, and there is no negative
trials. All trials are
for us to be able to learn. We need to learn from every
single patient. That means that our hypothesis was wrong.
It's okay. Let's go back to the basic science.
Let's continue to collaborate, and let's figure out
why it didn't work. How can we make it work?
And there were so many different immunotherapy approaches
also in early-stage
cancers, in resectable non-small cell lung cancer, in
gastric cancer, and newer approaches, but still
with limited efficacy. So we still have
much more to understand around
how we can
engage the immune system for a better
anti-tumor activity.
And last, I do want to mention all the
biomarkers and ctDNA that is really
moving from just exploratory
correlatives to really defining a new
stage in cancer, which is the
MRD.
And also,
it is something that
we need to embrace,
and it really
offers us an opportunity to maybe
for patients that have a minimal
residual disease or molecular residual disease, to
be able to still turn them around and
towards
the word that we are always afraid to say, but
around cure. And so
ctDNA, there was a mini symposium, and this is just a
highlight of all the presentations.
And you can see that the ctDNA role was not only
in MRD detection but also as a
prognostic and also looking at the
kinetics, at the response assessment.
So there are so many ways that we can use that.
And how about in neoadjuvant, adjuvant
setting? Can we aim for cure? Can we
lead to organ preservation? Can
we prime the immune system? And
there are so many exciting
presentations that we learned during
this meeting. And so with
that, I want to summarize. One is that if we would
have a wow award, it would go to KRAS.
So the wow award for this meeting goes to KRAS
because it's practice-changing, and I am
honored to be in this meeting and
witness these changes. And there are
also new potential targets. There are new
ADCs, but the payload remains a challenge.
There are some IO-IO combinations that showed some
modest
benefit, and so we need to better understand
how we can engage the anticancer
immune system. And also for the cellular therapies, we
need
to understand
and how to overcome the challenges in solid tumors.
But the CAR Ts did show promise in
pre-malignancyAnd biomarkers, ctDNA,
it's not anymore an exploratory tool, but it's
really reshaping the definition
and management of minimal residual
disease or molecular residual disease.
So how about future directions? So I believe in
precision oncology, we do need to have better
biomarker-guided combinations to delay or
overcome resistance. For ADCs, we need better,
newer targets. We need new payloads.
We need dual
targets, dual payloads. And also rational
combinations with immunotherapy and targeted
therapies.
For immunotherapy, we need to personalize it.
And also for cellular therapies, we need to be able to make
it more effective and more scalable for solid tumors.
And I did not mention AI, but I did have to add it
at last that we will need AI to be
able to integrate all the omics and all the
biomarkers
to be able to develop better anticancer
treatments. And with that, I want
to thank all patients that participated in these
trials or their caregivers, patient advocates,
all the investigators, all study teams.
I will thank again, Dr.
Jayesh Desai, my co-chair, Dr. Shu, for
your leadership and kindness, that it's so
inspiring. And the AACR team,
such amazing work, and my mentors, Dr.
Yap and Dr. Mary.
And with that, thank you so much.
Thank you, Dr. Dombrava, for such an
eloquent synthesis in these exciting developments.
I'm going to now turn it over to our immediate past president, Dr.
Lillian Siu. Just one word, she has been an
exemplary president. Dr. Siu.
Wow.
I don't know about you, but I am charged.
This has been a fantastic meeting.
Over 23,000 of you registered for this year's
meeting. We have received and heard over
7,500 abstracts, over 260 clinical
trials in this year's annual meeting.
Just to follow on Dr. Politi's,
adding to my tagline, precision, partnership,
purpose, passion,
I would say we made progress.
We made progress because of the collective efforts, wisdom,
innovation, and hard work of our entire scientific
community.
Thank you to all of you for being here, and thank you for showcasing
your hard work.
I need to thank many people. I know you have flights to catch, so
give me one more minute. I want to thank Paul,
Michelle, and Alice Shaw for their hard work to create a
fantastic program. I was the planning program co-chair last
year. You outdid us. Thank you.
I want to thank the Education Committee.
I want to thank the Clinical Trials Committee chaired by Dr. Desai and Dr.
Dombrava. I want to thank all the committees and subcommittee
members, all the chairs, and all the discussants.
I want to thank the AACR team, Lisa Holbein, Elena
Arallo, and many, many others, all of you who made this possible
behind the scene, in front of the scene, cameras, everything.
Of course, I have to thank our fearless leader, Dr.
Margaret Foti, who has made tremendous
effort and insight, and leadership to make this possible, and the AACR the
best cancer society in the world, and obviously to all
of you for coming here and joining us.
Last word, last line. AACR 2027
is on April 2nd to 7th in Orlando. I
am sure I'll see all of you there, and this will
be under the leadership of our president, Dr.
Keith Flaherty. So thank you.
Have a very safe journey home, and if you live here, thank you very
much. Enjoy your way home.